Hey! This is your travel host, Naomi.
I'd like to give you a tour of the top ten attractions of Kyoto, Japan.
Number 10: Gion district.
A wonderful traditional neighborhood in the city of Kyoto.
During your time here, you are likely to see geishas in their traditional attire.
Number 9: Bamboo grove.
Unlike any other place you are going to see...
...walking through the bamboo grove,...
...you are in a different world surrounded by the tall bamboo trees.
Number 8: Heian Shrine.
This Shinto shrine was constructed in 1895...
...and commemorates Kyoto's past emperors.
These days, it's a site for many local festivals.
Number 7: Kinkaku-ji.
Kyoto has numerous cultural sites.
Kinkaku-ji, the Buddhist temple of the golden pavilion,...
...is among Kyoto's 17 world cultural heritage sites.
Number 6: Kiyomizu.
Another famous temple of Kyoto built all the way back in the 8th century.
Locals enjoy the surrounding natural landscape...
...that changes throughout the year.
Number 5: Fushimi Inari Shrine.
Walking through the striking shrine gates,...
...you are transported into another world.
Many tradespeople come here to pray for prosperity of their businesses.
Number 4: Local culture.
In Japan, even the simple day-to-day things are fascinating.
You'll find that the local way of life is spiritual...
...as well as one that's harmonious with nature.
Number 3: Ginkaku-ji.
The temple was constructed in the 15th century.
Japanese architecture melds nature with buildings beautifully...
...and you clearly see that in this temple's gardens.
Number 2: Nijo Castle.
A large complex built in the early 17th century.
You can take the inside tour and witness its fortress like features...
...along with its emphasis on harmony with nature.
And number 1: Cherry blossom.
Kyoto is one of the world's most beautiful cities.
A perfect time to visit this city is during the cherry blossoms...
...when its great cultural attractions look even more stunning.
Keep watching our travel series. Ciao!